uh we have another one of these
completely kafkaesque moments in
american politics donald trump has
endorsed eric in a missouri republican
senate primary
both of the top candidates are named
eric and both erics are taking credit
saying i have been endorsed by donald
trump it is an absolutely bizarre
bizarre situation and donald trump again
as the daily beast reports throwing the
race into chaos
with his eric
endorsement check this out donald there
were questions about whether donald
trump would or would not endorse anyone
in this race one of the eric's eric
greitens was very much lobbying for the
trump endorsement he's done some wacky
things including bizarre campaign ads
and and so many different things the
primary is today
and last night
donald trump puts out the following
endorsement
there is a big election in the great
state of missouri by the way half the
words are capitalized just i'm not even
going to mention that as we go because
just half of the words are randomly
capitalized okay there is a big election
in the great state of missouri and we
must send a mega champion and true
warrior to the u.s senate someone who
will fight for border security election
integrity our military and great
veterans together with having a powerful
toughness on crime and the border we
need a person who will not back down to
the radical left lunatics who are
destroying our country
i trust the great people of missouri on
this one to make up their own minds much
as they did when they gave me landslide
victories in the 2016 and 2020 elections
and i am therefore proud to announce
that eric all caps eric
has my complete
and total endorsement
this is another
unbelievable
kafka-esque fiasco
both candidates are named eric he
doesn't say which eric he's endorsing
clearly trying to have it both ways no
matter which eric wins
trump can claim victory and the
undergirding
of this
is that
mega world the magats
are sort of divided on the race some of
them like eric greitens some of them
like eric schmidt some of them don't
know what's up and what's down in day
and night and they're just in a fog and
have absolutely no idea what's going on
whatsoever now earlier on there were
some anecdotal reports that trump was
planning on or intended to endorse eric
greitens but it genuinely doesn't appear
that that's the case now check this out
both of them
both eric's accepting the endorsement
eric greitens immediately posting
honored to have the support of president
trump we will maga
with this big picture that says
president trump endorses
eric greitens greitens also tweeting
quote i am honored to receive trump's
endorsement from the beginning i've been
the true maga champion
fighting against the rhino establishment
backing schmidt
president trump said it best when he
characterized schmidt's campaign as
great dishonesty in politics well i
guess then trump endorsed greitens right
well no not really schmidt also took
credit for the endorsement going to
twitter
with red alarm emojis saying endorsement
president trump
i'm grateful for president trump's
endorsement as the only america first
candidate who has actually fought for
election integrity border security and
against the left's indoctrination of our
kids i'll take that fight to the senate
to save america they both sound like
unhinged maga lunatics using all of the
hallmarks of
of that random capitalization of
non-proper nouns in their tweets
delusions of grandeur and general
confusion about how american politics
works they both sort of sound like
pretty good maga candidates so donald
trump it's really a cop-out initially it
seemed like trump was just confused like
trump intended to endorse one or the
other eric and ended up accidentally not
it now is looking abundantly clear that
this is just another trump cop-out and
he'll call this a victory no matter what
whichever of the eric's ends up winning
trump's going to say i got another one
put another slash mark in my win column
one of our sponsors is better help the
customized online therapy service that
offers video phone and live chat with
your therapist you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to you fill out a questionnaire to help
assess your specific needs and then
you're matched with a licensed therapist
in under 48 hours you can schedule
secure video and phone sessions you can
exchange unlimited messages with your
therapist and you can request a new
therapist at any time for any reason at
no charge talking to a therapist doesn't
mean there's something wrong with you it
means you're doing something for
yourself and for your wellness you get
your car serviced you work out you see
the doctor to prevent physical illness
and disease
therapy is the same thing anyone can
benefit from it i think it's very
important join the two million plus
people who have taken charge of their
mental health with better help get 10
percent off your first month at
betterhelp.com pacman the link is down
below